In a recent interview with Charlie Rose on "60 Minutes",...
...Microsoft founder and chairman Bill Gates spoke emotionally...
...about his last visit with Apple founder and CEO Steve Jobs.
Gates welled up at the memory of his last conversation with Jobs in May 2011.
And talked about what?
All about what we've learned, about families, anything.
The conversation was positive for the two friends and former rivals.
No, he was not being melancholy like you know, "Oh, I've been gypped."
He was very forward-looking about, "Oh, we haven't really improved education with technology."
You know, "What do you think?"
Gates also admitted Jobs was the better designer...
...after Rose asked what Jobs had that he wished he'd had.
Oh, his sense of design, that everything had to fit a certain aesthetic.
The fact that he, with his little engineering background as he had,...
...it shows that design can lead you in a good direction.
And so, phenomenal products came out of it.